a final question if you can't if you
couldn't own or buy Bitcoin what other
digital asset would you buy yeah it's
great question it would probably be
digitize traditional assets right or
tokenized trishal assets i don't think
that trishal assets are just are gonna
go away what we're gonna see is a
similar transition from what we saw and
what I call it the analog age of
security so stocks used to be physical
pieces of paper that we would buy and
sell and transact so you wouldn't buy
XLP or you wouldn't buy t-rex y know
these I ultimately don't think that they
have the same value that these other
assets have right my my belief is that
stocks what gives them value right again
GDP revenue profits etc all the stream
of income from a company that's doing
something with an asset right so
everything that makes those valuable
that doesn't change you're just changing
the technology form factor of which you
will buy that asset so you won't buy
that electronic youssef anymore you'll
now by that same stock and risk be a
digitizer tokenized stock I actually
like those assets they're not bad assets
and I don't think that Bitcoin competes
with those assets what Bitcoin competes
with very specifically of their
currencies right and those currencies
even if they change their technology
form factor I think the monetary policy
is bad bitcoins monetary policy is
superior but all of these other assets
that are quote unquote utility tokens
either their utility in terms of they
give you access to something so they're
not really an investment it's more of AI
get utility or some good or service in
exchange so you're separating OU's X up
here's an example simply because I've
been to be Brad recently yep you see no
connection between what ripple is trying
to achieve with their network and the
value of x RP yes so and I think Brad
would would say this right is rippled
the software company is different than x
RP the token and I think that part of
the problem is that retail investors
have believed that by buying x RP they
have exposure the financial performance
ripple that's obviously not true I won't
even go there right but on top of that
what ends up happening is if
ripple is successful that does not
necessarily mean that X RP ends up being
successful right and so also that means
that x RP could go up in value and
ripple could go out of business right
speculators could drive the price etc so
when you get this disjoint mminton x RP
and ripple or other assets that have a
similar mekin
what ends up happening is I as a
investor actually want to own equity in
the software company because there's
profits there's assets there's all
revenues etc I don't want to own the
asset that may or may not be there in
the future and doesn't have any
underlying utility or value driver that
I can point to and say I have confidence
that that's going to last Bitcoin is
different because it's backed by the
most secure computer network in the
world final final question I read an
interview with you in 2019 that said 50%
of your net wealth is in Bitcoin
probably regret saying that actually
where it is today yeah so I've never saw
any Bitcoin I don't know what the
numbers are today and in fact I've
bought more Bitcoin but in my whole
thought process here is I'm relatively
young compared to most people right and
the other thing people never ask me is
like what do I do with the rest
it's either cash or real estate right
and so for the most part I'm pretty
risk-averse with half my portfolio I'm
obviously very risky with the other half
kind of a barbell strategy given my age
kind of my risk tolerance level it
actually makes a lot of sense
diversify even though a significant
chunk of your wealth of course and if
you look right and you know again when I
talk to kind of traditional investment
so well how much of your wealth is in
dollar denominated stocks for example so
when we have a day like yesterday we had
where the stock market draws down you
know a material percentage for the for
the ball today that it's used to all of
a sudden you may have 50 60 70 80 % of
your wealth that's all in one single
asset class right I'm individual
companies are different and all that but
you're still exposing yourself to a
similar risk level in terms of
everything is correlated it's all gonna
move together bitcoins no different it
just happens to be that I've made a very
calculated investment decision and one
that I'm willing to be comfortable and
live with well reconvene in 2021 when
it's a hundred thousand awesome thank
you so much